the songs of the story in New Jersey
lawmakers are due to vote later today on
a bill to legalize recreational marry
marijuana some people call it mary-jane
the measure needs to pass both chambers
uh so I've been told
you need to pass both chambers of the
Statehouse if it does New Jersey would
join ten other states and the District
of Columbia that already legalized pot
Vermont is the only one that changed its
laws through the state legislature the
others legalized pot through ballot
initiatives Meg Oliver's at the harmony
medical marijuana dispensary in Secaucus
with a look at the controversial
proposal make good morning to you Gail
good morning from under some loud fans
and yellow lights that simulate the Sun
workers here are preparing for a sudden
increase in demand but it's still
unclear whether there are enough votes
to pass this measure later today we sat
down with the state's governor who
brings this as a social justice issue
since Colorado in Washington became the
first to legalize weed in 2012 a growing
number of states have followed now New
Jersey's governor wants in we're digging
out of decades of in justices here
I believe folks deserve a second chance
Phil Murphy calls the drug situation in
his state unacceptable marijuana arrests
have risen faster New Jersey than
anywhere else and a report by the
American Civil Liberties Union shows
black New Jerseyans are three times more
likely to be arrested for marijuana
possession than whites despite similar
usage rates we're not inventing
marijuana it exists he's pushing a bill
to legalize pot for people 21 and over
taxing it at 42 dollars an ounce and
speeding up expungement of marijuana
related criminal records
Murphy calls it a game changer to get
the business out of the hands of the bad
guys to correct the social and justices
to regulate it and do it right New
Jersey's six medical marijuana
facilities are bracing for the bill to
pass as soon as governor Murphy took
office he asked us to expand our
capacity but leaders of at least 60
towns opposed the measure preemptively
banning marijuana within city limits
Cranberry Township is among them Jay
Taylor's mayor of this town of
3,900 people there's concern about what
happens to the kids in the community
he says legalizing weed for adults could
expose more children to what he
considers a gateway drugs the idea that
we legalize marijuana today and that
it's just gonna stop in marijuana it's
not gonna lead to anything else as a
fallacy the measure now faces strong
opposition in the state legislature
there is no question that legalizing
marijuana will have a significant impact
on our residents opponents point to
reports of issues in other states that
legalize pot there was an increase in
traffic deaths in Colorado and lower
than expected tax revenues in
Massachusetts how close is it right now
this is very close this is razor thin
and it's gonna go right down as they say
right down to the wire
governor Murphy says he's been working
the phones to get every possible vote if
this measure passes marijuana would be
available for recreational purchase
within six months Viana
it's definitely something that we're
seeing happen more and more throughout
the country though it's still a big
debate meg thank you